- Hi everyone, Sal here.
Welcome to the Homeroom live stream.
We have a very exciting guest today.
Laurie Santos professor at Yale university
who teaches a class called
"Psychology and the Good Life."
So it's gonna be a really
interesting conversation.
I encourage all of you all
to start putting questions
on the message boards
on Facebook and YouTube,
or wherever you're watching this.
And the team will surface
as many of these as possible
to myself and Laurie as we
get into the conversation.
Before we get into that,
I will give my standard announcements.
A reminder that Khan Academy
is a not-for-profit organization.
We can only exist through donations
from folks like yourself,
so if you're in a position to do so,
please think about going
to khanacademy.org/donate
and making a donation.
I also want to give a special shout out
to several organizations
that have stepped up,
especially during COVID.
Khan Academy was already
running into deficit pre-COVID.
Our costs have gone up dramatically
because our traffic has
gone up dramatically,
and we're trying to accelerate
a whole bunch of things
to keep everyone learning.
So special thanks to Bank of
America, Google.org, AT&T,
Fastly, Novartis, and many
other supporters of Khan Academy
throughout the year,
including many of y'all,
but we still need more help,
especially we have a very
big gap still for 2021.
So any help you can provide is
very, very much appreciated.
Also want to remind everyone about
"Homeroom with Sal" the podcast,
which is a flavor of what
you're seeing right now.
It's essentially episodes of "Homeroom"
edited into a podcast format
so that you can enjoy it
while also doing things like
safely driving or walking,
or not being distracted
by my bizarre face.
So encourage you to check that out
wherever you get your podcasts.
So with that, I'm excited
to introduce Laurie Santos.
Laurie, thanks for joining us.
- Thanks so much for having me on.
- So maybe a good place
to start, your class,
Psychology and the Good
Life, what is that about?
And why do you feel that
it needs to be taught?
- Yeah, yeah well, the
class really started
when I took on a new role at Yale.
So I'm a professor at Yale.
I've been teaching
there for over a decade,
but in just the last couple years,
I took on this new role as
head of college on campus.
So, Yale was one of these strange schools
like Hogwarts in Harry Potter,
where there's like these
colleges within the college.
I'm head of Silliman College,
but what that means is that I
live on campus with students.
I'm like with them in the trenches,
like eating with them in the
dining hall and hanging out.
And honestly, when I took on the new role,
I didn't like what I was seeing.
I was seeing this college
student mental health crisis
up close and personal
with so many students
reporting feeling depressed and anxious,
or just like stressed out about life.
And fast-forwarding, I'd
have so many conversations
with students where I'm
like, how's it going?
They're like, oh, if I could
just get through midterms,
or, oh, if I could just
like get to spring break.
it was like not being
present and enjoying things.
And so it made me realize that
just needed some practical
strategies for like how to feel better
in the modern day and age.
And so the class really
emerged out of that.
It's a psychology class.
It's like a lot of introductory
psychology material,
but it's all about the
science of wellbeing.
It's like evidence based strategies
you can use to feel better.
And the best part about the
classes is the homework,
which wasn't the typical,
like y'all class homework.
It was homework like
meditate or make a new social
connection or savor your
next eating experience.
It was homework designed to put
those practices into effect.
And so now I put this class together
like a normal Ivy league class,
just assuming, you know, 30
or 40 students would take it.
That's pretty typical for
a psychology class here.
Was a little astounded
when over a thousand students enrolled.
In the end, we had a quarter
of the Yale student body
tried to take the class,
which showed me the students
are voting with their feet.
You know, they don't like this culture
of feeling academically stressed
and overwhelmed all the time.
And I think they really
wanted some evidence based
strategies they could use to feel better.
- Now on one level,
what you just said is
surprising that it's so popular,
but on another level,
it's so obvious that it should be that way
because, what are we doing anything for?
Why are we even living our lives
if not to have a good life,
to be happy and to be in the
moment and to be present.
So I have a ton of questions
and already questions
are starting to come in.
I'm curious, two things.
One is, do you think that
things are different now
than they were when I said,
I think I look a lot older than you.
When I was gonna say, when
you and I went to school,
I'm amazed to meet very
accomplished professors
who at least look a lot younger than me.
(laughing)
But you think things are different
than when we went to
school or generations past.
And then what are the main tools
that you're trying to get folks
to help deal with that?
- Yeah, yeah.
Well, there's some data on this.
I mean, the self reported rates
of mental health issues have
been skyrocketing, right?
And we could say that maybe
that's because there was more
stigma to admitting you're depressed
or anxious or something
when we were in school.
But those reasons have been skyrocketing
in just the last five years, right?
So I don't think since 2016,
the stigma has gone down
that much about saying
I'm feeling anxious or feeling depressed.
But we're seeing things like (inaudible).
- In 2016, that's a short time period
till now you seeing data.
So sorry, I interrupted.
- No, no, no.
It's crazy.
The rates are skyrocketing
since 2009, right?
Just about 10 years,
double the rates of depression
in college aged students.
Terrible, right?
I mean, so these things are going up fast.
The million dollar question is why?
And the honest answer is
that we just don't know.
There's probably a lot
of factors going on.
You know, we're more
socially disconnected.
We're interacting more on
social media and technology.
I think there's a lot more pressure
on students to go to a good school.
And this kind of meritocracy narrative
has kind of embedded all of our brains
in a different way than
when we were in school.
So, lots of different factors,
but what we know is like
it is getting worse.
And so we need some solutions.
And so that gets to your next question.
Would you like,
okay, what are the solutions?
What are the, you know, what
are the things we can do?
And one of the things the
course teaches is that,
we were all trying to be happier.
It's not like people want to feel
depressed and anxious, right?
The problem is that we go
about it the wrong way.
We think we need like the next accolade
or we need the next, you know paycheck,
or we need to change our circumstances.
And the data just suggested that
that is not the path to higher wellbeing.
Higher wellbeing comes from our practices.
A big thing is just social connection.
You know, carving out time
to spend with family members
and people you care about and love.
Wellbeing comes from being other oriented
rather than selfish.
I think there's this whole
idea for students nowadays,
that you gotta focus
on you and your grades
and your accolades and your test scores.
But the data suggests that happiness
comes from focusing on other people,
the happiest people out there
are people who do good for other people.
And so one of the homework
assignments we give in my classes
is that students have to do
these random acts of kindness.
And so, you know, just plug for
khanacademy.org/donate, right?
One of the leading predictors of happiness
is if you donate to good causes.
So, you know, you can do
something nice for Khan Academy
and boost your wellbeing.
But then there's other just simple things
like healthy habits, just
something as simple as sleep,
which we know nowadays young people
are doing less stuff, right?
The simple act of getting
seven to eight hours of sleep,
can statistically boost your wellbeing.
You know, people who
are getting five hours
actually have mood levels.
They look like they're
clinically depressed
in public is they're not
getting enough sleep.
So the answers are really
simple in a funny way.
They almost seem like kind of trite,
but actually none of us
are doing them, right?
And so I think seeing the science,
when you see a graph that shows,
you know, hey, if you do
random acts of kindness,
here's your happiness.
Versus if you don't, it's over here,
it's like, Oh, it's hard
to argue with those data.
- First of all, our
philanthropy team thanks you.
Because I think we're gonna take that clip
of what you just said.
And actually I would love
to see the graphs too.
I'm already seeing our next
email ask for donation saying,
"We're gonna do you a favor by donating.
We're gonna make you happier.
And here's the empirical
evidence why that is true."
'Cause that feels like a win, win.
'Cause you could imagine,
you know, sometimes is
hard to ask for money.
- What's awesome is (inaudible) like tips.
So many of these tips
actually have this win-win feature, right?
Like by the act of doing
something to support yourself
and your self care, you're
actually helping your community.
You're helping the people around you.
And we talk a lot about the evidence
for emotional contagion, right?
Like my wellbeing is gonna affect
the wellbeing of people around me.
So by like doing the right
sorts of things for yourself,
that's actually a way that
you can help your friends.
That's the way you can
help your family members.
Like it's putting your
oxygen mask on first
doesn't just give you the oxygen,
it kind of helps everybody around you too.
- Laurie, I'm not kidding.
I think you've just defined our like,
winter giving campaign.
Like help yourself by helping
the children of the world.
But going into, I mean,
there's so much that you
said that I'd love to impact.
There's already questions coming in.
And I think this is on
a lot of folks as mine,
Niche786 on YouTube saying, "How can we,
oh, this is, oh no, this
is Selena Chang actually.
I'll get to Niche's question as well.
You know, what advice do you....
So you're talking about,
you know, taking your time,
random acts of kindness,
getting enough sleep, being present.
But, you know, the question here is
how, you know, students need to juggle
workload and other activities and stress?
I think there's a lot of
kissing, that sounds nice.
But I got my, you know, I
got to prepare for the SAT.
I got this grade, I got this project.
I got to get my extracurriculars right.
I mean, right now we're in
college admission season
for, you know, the early decision.
And early decision,
just the words have stress in it.
- Right, You've just (inaudible).
- What would you tell this folks.
- Part of it is honestly
getting your priorities right.
It's recognizing that you
are not your grades, right?
You are not your accolades.
You are not what happens
on that early decision.
You know, that you will
live and have a happy life.
Even if you don't get into
your first choice school.
Or worse, the school your parents
think you need to go to, right?
Like there are a lot of healthy paths.
The other thing is that we know
that people who are feeling burnt out,
you know, if you're really in serious
mental health dysfunction,
like you're not gonna
be learning well, right?
You know, when I look out
at rates in college rates
of depression at places like 40%
of nationally college students
report being depressed.
Over 60% report feeling
overwhelmingly anxious.
Like they're not learning
this stuff I'm teaching them, right?
You have to support your
mental health first.
And then those academic
achievements come later.
This is the thing that's
so shocking to students,
but like the data, just bear this out.
And in my class,
I teach all about the
evidence of sleep for,
for improving grades, right?
Like just the act of sleep.
It means you're gonna be more likely
to get higher grades.
And I have students who are like, okay,
it's midterm season.
This feels really counterintuitive to me.
Normally I would stay up,
like tons of hours and not get any sleep,
but I'm gonna try it
and then they would come
back to me afterwards
and report like you are right.
Like I did better on my midterms this year
than I have in years.
And I feel better, right?
'Cause I'm not like super sleep deprived.
And so I think it's a
matter of like overcoming
these misconceptions we have.
We think we need to be on full throttle,
a hundred percent of the time
and that's the way to get stuff done.
But counter-intuitively
focusing on your wellbeing first
might actually be a way to make
those grades, the accolades,
all that stuff easier.
And then you get both for free.
- No, I can't reinforce
more of what you just said.
You know, I had the
blessing of my first job
after business school.
I worked for a small hedge fund in Boston.
And my boss who was actually
a Yale grad by the way,
his name is Dan will.
And I remember I was ready.
I was like, I'm in a hedge fund.
I'm gonna work 80 hours a week.
I'm ready to just,
and I remember him telling
me after like the first week,
"Sal why are you here?
The market's closed, go home."
I was like, okay Dan,
I'm gonna go work from home.
He's like, "No, no.
Sal, our whole job is to
not make bad decisions
and make a few good decisions.
The best thing you can do for your work
is to go home and live your life,
and not think about work for the next,
whatever 12 hours or 16 hours.
And it was kind of this
mind blowing thing to me,
but he was right.
I mean, he was a very successful investor.
I learned a lot from him.
It also created time and space for me
to do things like Khan Academy.
So I, you know, it completely resonates
with what I, what I've heard.
You know, actually 76 questions
actually was very similar
to the previous question.
But I'll ask it again,
because I think we're,
I think you're chipping away
at what people's worldview a little bit.
And I'm sure you've experienced this
every time that you teach the class
where people are like,
okay, maybe I could
sleep a little bit more.
Maybe I could do a few random acts.
No, but there's still all this stress
and I still have all of this.
You know, initially saying,
how do you stay cool and content there,
you have peer pressure.
You see other people doing this,
you have all these responsibilities.
And I think adults are,
it's not just college students.
I think adults are in the exact same boat.
- No, totally.
I mean, you know, it
was one of the reasons
my class went so viral, right?
Was that, you know,
I was giving this stuff to Yale students,
but I got all these emails,
like I'm 40, I'm 50.
Like I need these tips too, right?
I mean, I think, you know,
we as adults don't
necessarily know how to do it.
And I think that's why there's so much
mental health dysfunction,
but I think we've really
gotten off track, right?
I mean, I think one of the things
that's surprising is that the
research suggests that if
you focus on happiness first,
other good stuff will come, right?
We think we have to get
the good stuff first
and then we can be happy.
We need like perfect grades
and get into the perfect college
and then I'll be happy.
The data is funny.
It suggests the causal
arrow goes the opposite way.
There's data, for example,
that if you are in a more positive mood,
that you're more likely to
find a creative solution
to a tough problem.
They did this study with doctors
who have a kind of like, you know,
house level medical diagnosis
that's really tricky.
You're in a positive mood.
You're more likely to see the problem.
There's evidence suggesting
that your mood levels
and your cheerfulness levels at 18
actually predict how
much you're gonna make
when you're 30 years old, right?
And so all of you students out there
who are making yourselves miserable
by not sleeping and
worrying about college,
it turns out the causal
arrow might go the other way.
Your cheerfulness right now
might be predicting a whole host of stuff
that's gonna affect your salary later on.
And so I think it's a problem.
I think as a society, we
really have it backwards.
We actually need to be putting
our oxygen mask on first.
It doesn't just affect
like, Oh, we feel good.
That feels nice.
It affects the bottom line in a deep way.
- That's, super powerful.
And there's a bunch of questions.
There are a lot of the same flavor
where I think people
are, they see the goal,
they've heard what you just said.
I think you've, you're convincing them.
But, you know from Facebook, Dolce Castro,
Garcia currently I'm overstressing
and feel like I'm drowning in schoolwork.
How can I deal with that in a healthy way
that allows me to keep working,
but not feel like I can't breathe.
Thanks, I love the science
of wellbeing course.
YouTube casually obsessed says,
what is the best way to
reclaim your attention span?
I think people are just looking
for, you know, baby steps.
- Yeah, We'll, a couple of them,
a lot of the practices that really help.
The good news is they
don't take a lot of time.
And actually that's one of the other tips,
is that a big predictor
of people feeling awful,
like serious depression, is
people's level of time famine.
So this feeling that you're
really hungry for time,
you're just frantic
about time all the time.
And what's amazing is that time famine
the data suggests is going up,
even though our free amount of time
is actually going up to.
It's like the perception
that we're so stressed
for time is going up
even as we have more free time.
And so we don't want to
like take more time off.
We're getting more stressed.
Like you don't want to
get all stressed out
about like doing more of these
wellness activities, right?
But the good news is that a lot of them
don't take very much time, right?
Like you can do a random act
of kindness in two minutes.
You know, you could do a
quick five minute meditation
and just follow your
breath for five minutes.
You're not gonna lose
that much study time.
If you take five minutes
to do a meditation.
And what you'll find is
the act of doing that
is gonna give you back dividends
in terms of your attention and so on.
So one of the things I recommend is like,
especially in this zoom time,
when we're all experiencing so
much zoom fatigue right now,
is in between classes
or in between meetings,
just a three minute
deep breath meditation,
where you just breathe in deeply
into your, ideally
breathe into your stomach.
So big stomach breath in, and
then a really slow exhale.
And again, it sounds, you know silly,
you know people say like, Oh,
take a deep breath
when you're trying to be like all,
you know, worried about you
being stressed and things.
But scientifically, what happens is that
that deep breath activates
your vagus nerve.
And if you're taking a
biology class on Khan Academy,
you probably know that we have this thing
called the Sympathetic
nervous system, right?
That activates, that's our
like, fight or flight system.
That's like, Oh gosh,
the tiger is coming or an exam's coming,
I'm so freaked out.
Well, you wanna activate
to decrease that stress
is your parasympathetic nervous system,
the other part.
And you do that
through activation of
the vagus nerve, right?
When you're taking those deep breaths,
there's no tiger that
could be coming to get you.
And it just signals to your body
to kind of go back to that distress mode.
And that takes like three minutes.
And so, you know,
that's one quick tip that
you can kind of build in.
But another one is just like, again,
it's, it's a broader
more meta issue, right?
One of the reasons we're so stressed
is that we're going after the wrong stuff.
You know, what if everybody on this call
prioritize making a little bit more time
for the people they care about.
Even if it's just like 10,
15 minutes a day, you know.
Yeah, you'll have less time
for school, that's okay.
Like the priority is social connection.
That would pay huge dividends
where you're feeling a little
more socially connected,
you get a little bit more
laughter in your day.
Like the problem is that
we have these priorities
that might not be getting
us the things we want,
including good grades, you know,
the best jobs afterwards and so on.
We might be going about it the wrong way.
- No, that so resonates.
And I've shared this on
this live stream many times.
I've become a religious meditator.
I do it every day, half an hour.
And you're exactly right.
It's very easy to rationalize that.
And you don't have to do half an hour.
I started doing 10 minutes a day.
But you can rationalize,
Oh, I don't have time for that half hour.
I gotta get the kids ready,
I gotta, you know,
have these meetings, et cetera.
But for me, it's clear
causality that if I meditate,
I kind of disassociate myself
from all of these made
up tigers in my head,
that are like, what are
people gonna think of me?
What if that initiative of
Khan Academy doesn't work?
What if we're not able
to raise enough money?
All of these tigers that
really aren't gonna eat me.
And that frankly, I forget the next week.
But if I just take a...
I actually viewed as
my 30 minute vacation,
I feel like I'm on the beach.
Even though it's just in my head.
That, Marcus Marshall really
is the famous Roman emperor
and his meditations.
He said, you know,
"People wanna always say
they want to go to the beach
or get away from it all."
All you have to do is go inward.
All you have to do is realize that you can
just get away from it all.
If you kind of separate yourself
form your identity, your ego,
all of these things
that you identify with.
And I gotta to say it always works.
It changes my mood.
I become more affectionate to my wife.
I give her a hug and a kiss.
Instead of trying to get my kids
out the door as fast as possible,
I'm hugging them.
You know, if they say, Dad
I'm late, I'm like, it's okay.
You know, and we're happier.
So I completely agree with you're saying.
Are there other, you know,
I'd love to, you know, from the science,
are there things that surprised you?
Things that you're like, wow.
Yeah, that's even another data point.
that's so counterintuitive or surprising.
- Yeah, I think another one
that really surprised me,
is the importance of something
like gratitude, right?
It sounds so cheesy.
Like, Oh, be grateful.
Like it's like some bad, you know,
social media thing
that your parents will share on Facebook
or something like that.
But, the data suggests that
like the act of complaining,
which kind of feels good,
we have this prediction
and that will feel nice to gripe
and complain with our friends
or make memes complaining about stuff
and talking about how
crappy everything is.
Like the data really suggests
that that's actually the opposite.
That taking some time
to count your blessings,
even when things feel really bad,
even when things feel really stressed,
is a way to kinda give yourself
a wellbeing boost, right?
There's data suggesting that
the simple act of scribbling down
three to five things you're
grateful for every day,
significantly boost your happiness
in as little as two weeks,
but what's more surprising
is there's data suggesting
that experiencing gratitude
can actually bump up
your willpower, right?
You know, so some of like,
have to sit down and do
that college application
or that late hard project
that you got to start work on.
And it feels really tough.
You want the like willpower to sit there.
It turns out what gets you out, gratitude.
The simple act of like,
recognizing that you have benefits in life
makes you feel like, yeah,
things are going pretty good.
I can, like, I can do this
thing that feels a little hard.
And so again, that feels so
totally counterintuitive to me.
You know, if you asked my brain,
what would feel better like griping
and complaining to your friends
or reading a lot of like
angry means on Reddit
or something like, I'll be like that.
That's what my brain
thinks is gonna feel good.
But actually what would
feel better is, you know,
to text a friend of
mine and say, you know,
hey, I'm so great....
I don't say this often,
but thanks for being there.
I'm really grateful for you.
Or to a parent or something like that.
Or even just privately write down
on like your phone on some app,
the things that you really love in life
and the things that
you're really proud of.
Like, it sounds cheesy,
but it really works.
- And that is so easy.
I mean, you literally, it takes seconds.
It just at the moment when you see someone
should appreciate them at all,
let them know that.
You know, all the questions
that have been coming in.
They're all a lot of the same flavor.
I mean, what you've
seen as a college head,
just a lot of stressed out folks.
And I think we're making
headway in this conversation.
My question is, why is your course
kind of just like a one off course?
Why shouldn't, I mean, to
me, this feels obvious.
I've talked to other
university presidents,
professors, guidance, counselors.
This should be like more men, your course.
And not just your course,
but like the practices you're describing,
it should be like, I don't know,
it feels like it should
just be part of the tissue
of our education system
and probably work as well.
- Yeah, I mean, I agree completely.
We're trying to get this content
into as many high schools
right now as we can.
So if you're a high school student
and you really want to see this content,
or if you're an educator and
you want to see this content,
let me know, and then we'll
really try to get it in.
You just drop me an email
and I'll be happy to send
you more information.
But yeah, I mean, I think
what's amazing is that,
this stuff is needed to
educate students well, right?
We simply are not meeting our
mission to teach students,
computer science or math or
Chaucer with 40% of young people
reporting that they're too
depressed to function most days.
Like the content is just
not getting in there.
And so I think we really
do need to think seriously
about whether or not
educators need to be building
this kind of mental health
protective strategies
into their content that
they're already developing.
- Yeah. And it's so simple.
I mean, I'll say what
I'm getting from you,
sleep, meditation,
gratitude, being present.
All of those things, I mean...
- You forgot the most (inaudible)
random acts of kindness
and donate to khanacademy
- Oh yeah, and random acts of kindness
and donating to Khanacademy.
Yes, maybe the most important one.
I'll put it.
They're all very important.
Where's your level,
what are you looking into now?
What are your areas of research?
What are the questions you're
trying to learn more about?
- Yeah, well, we're doing two things
on the kind of publicizing side.
As I said, we're really
trying to get this content
into as many schools and
classrooms as possible.
'Cause I do think it, I mean,
the data really just suggests
it just makes completely a difference
in terms of boosting people's wellbeing,
but also giving them
the bandwidth, you know,
to achieve in other domains too.
But another thing I'm
really struggling with
is why this stuff is so hard, right?
Like I'm the professor that
teaches this stuff, right?
I know the data,
it should be really easy for me
to meditate all the time
and do these random acts of kindness
and, you know, get enough sleep.
And it's still hard for me.
And so I'm really interested
in this disconnect
between knowing what you should be doing
and actually putting it into practice.
And so we're trying to come
up with different techniques
we can use to nudge people's behavior,
that you can use to
nudge your own behavior
in the right way.
I think the next class
that I teach at Yale
will be about those kinds of things.
All right, now you know
what you're supposed to do.
All right, let's actually do it.
- And what do you think
is that, what is that?
I mean, you mentioned the
sympathetic parasympathetic,
which is, you know, we humans,
maybe other animals do it too,
but if you know, if there's a tiger,
yeah, it makes sense that
your body goes into overdrive,
you know, all of your
stress hormones get released
and blood flows to your muscle.
But then we have this
chronic stress of like,
Oh, I better do good in that
thing three weeks from now,
or I better raise enough
money for Khan Academy.
Otherwise it'll all go away.
You know, and it's like,
you're constantly being chased by a tiger.
What's going on in our heads,
is that evolutionary favorable,
that's made us plan and, you know,
we're miserable but we're able to make
a more successful society.
I mean, why does that exist?
- Yeah, Well, natural selection
is not about us being happy.
Natural selection just once
(inaudible) that our genes
into the next generation.
And I think, you know,
that's worth remembering
that you're walking around
with this baggage in your head.
That's not about your bandwidth.
It's ready to push you, you know,
to the point to your
breaking point, right?
And I think, you know,
if you look in evolution,
you see that there are these, you know,
like different Rhoda creatures
who reproduce so much,
they die in one generation.
And I worry that this is what
we're pushing our students towards, right?
You know, they are at the breaking point
in terms of their mental health
to kind of achieve
the kinds of things we
want them to achieve.
And I think part of it
is we need as a society
to kind of scale that back
or else the consequences
are gonna be really steep.
But I think the beauty is that you can,
even if you don't feel like
your school is doing that,
or your family's doing that,
you can scale it back in your own head.
Through the kind of practices
we've been talking about.
Even just this idea of acceptance, right?
You know, like your
college admissions process
is gonna be what it's gonna be.
You've done your best.
Can you just be with that and accept that.
You know, the uncertainty of
the modern era is, you know,
going on like COVID and all
the things we're facing,
like you can't stop that
uncertainty necessarily,
but can you stop your
reaction to the uncertainty?
And I think that's one of the
things we realize is that you,
there's a lot of stuff you
don't have control over,
which can really affect us.
But there's always one thing
you do have control over,
which is your own attitude,
which is your own behavior.
And as you're talking about style,
all these techniques
like Marcus a really has talked about
that you can use to kinda
come to acceptance on that.
One of my favorite ones is
a technique called Rain.
This has been popularized
by a meditation teacher
named Tara Brock.
And it's a technique you can use
whenever you're feeling
a negative emotion.
The acronym rain stands
for are recognized like,
Oh, this is sadness.
This is frustration.
I'm mad at my parents.
This is fear about college.
Like, this is stress,
recognize what it is,
then allow it like, okay, you're cool.
You can be here.
Like, it's like a bad dinner guest,
or like a bad person who
showed up at your house.
You don't kick them out,
but you just allow it.
There's gonna be there and
they're gonna gonna go.
And you, I investigate, like,
what does it feel like in my body,
get that kind of bodily awareness.
And then you do the end,
which I think, you know,
people who study at Khan
Academy struggle with.
And the end is nurture, which
is like the self compassion.
It's not gonna help you
to beat yourself up.
So what can you do to nurture yourself?
Like it sucks to feel
uncertain or frustrated
or sad or scared or
whatever you're feeling.
What can you do to be nice to yourself?
Not kinda like, again,
I'm gonna blow everything
off and watch Netflix,
or like, you know, scroll on Reddit.
What can you do to be really
nutritiously nice for yourself?
What do you actually need right now?
And so that practice is
one that I use myself,
especially a lot of in the COVID time
when there's a lot of uncertainty
and scary stuff happening,
like recognize like, Oh, this sucks,
but I can be with it.
And investigate and kind of nurture it.
And this is exactly what the Stoics
like, Marcus Aurelius we're talking about.
You can't control the outside world,
but you can control your reaction to it.
- And just touching on that same idea,
there's question here from
Facebook, Gisela Padilla-Bovino.
I mean, you've touched on this
and I'll expand her question a little bit.
She's asking, "What other micro habits
do you suggest for everyday wellbeing?"
I'll extend it.
And this conversation has gone way faster.
The more I enjoy it, the faster it goes.
You know, what other micro habits,
I think we're all looking
for these very insightful,
I call them hacks,
call them whatever you want,
but they're micro habits.
But I'm also curious about your day,
like, make it tangible for us.
I mean, you're a by external observer,
you're a professor at Yale
seems like a stressful job.
You have a lot of responsibilities.
How do you, you know,
give us a day of your life
and how you manage these things.
- Yeah, well you said
some of the meditation
is huge gratitude.
I really just, I have like a
little notes thing on my phone
where I just try to write things down.
Another new one that I think
can be really powerful students is,
making good use of what's
called Time confetti.
So I mentioned that we were
all feeling more time damaged,
but we actually have more time.
Like, that's a disconnect what's up.
What's up is that we have more time,
but it's broken up into
these tiny little chunks.
This is what researcher,
Ashley Williams best time confetti, right?
Like little pieces here and there.
And it can feel like, Oh, I
don't have that much time.
I have five minutes.
Like, I'll just scroll on social media
or I'll do something stupid.
I'll get like a little
dopamine reward hit,
but not achieve anything real
for my like nutritious healthiness.
Ashley williams, she does making
what she calls a time confetti list.
Like when you have that
five minutes here and there
and what can you really do with it.
Again, not schoolwork.
Like what can you do with
it to connect with a friend
or have a like good
moment with your family,
or experienced some gratitude
or just do those deep
breaths that I mentioned.
And so this is a technique
I've stolen from Ashley.
Actually I have a list of
my time confetti lists.
And it's hard, you know,
if this call ends a little early,
I'll look at my, I'll be like, Oh,
I'll check my email or I'll
do I'll scroll on right.
And something Is like, nope,
I look at my time confetti list.
And I'm like, Oh,
I should text a friend or, Oh,
I should set up that
coffee date for the future
that I've been putting off, right?
Like what are things that
you can do nutritiously
for your wellbeing?
Not just like blow off the time.
Then you'll kind of feel
like you're a little
less time famished
and that can do wonders
for your wellbeing.
- I love that.
I love that term time confetti,
because now that you've
named it, I'm like, yeah,
there's tons of time
confetti all over the place.
And you know,
once I started getting into meditation,
now I'm almost addicted to it.
You know, even when
I'm on a traffic light,
Normally if I was at a big intersection,
I'm like, Oh, there's two,
two and a half minutes
of my life gone.
Now I'm like, Oh,
I got two and a half minutes,
now I'll call it time confetti.
And I'll, you know, I don't close my eyes
cause I need to pay attention to light.
But I'll say,
I'm just gonna look at this
very meditative red light
and just breathe deeply.
And then like, I'm like, Oh, it's over.
I gotta go, all right.
(Sal laughing)
But I love that.
And you can text, well, one last question,
because we've been kind of
talking about it on the margin.
You just alluded to it.
You know, a lot of people are
talking about social media,
even in the recent trends. ,
we've had people like Jonathan Haidton.
This live stream talk about,
he seems to point the
finger at social media,
being a reason why,
especially this generation of young people
who grew up on social media
seem especially prone to
anxiety or depression.
Are there some rules
that you would recommend
even that you're practicing yourself
or that you would want to do with
your, you know, the students
you work with or your family?
- Yeah, I think the rule that I use a lot
and I suggest a lot to my students is,
to kind of mindfully pay attention
to what feels nutritious.
This is hard, right?
Our brains are telling us
to go after the wrong stuff.
And this is natural
selection's fault, right?
Like, you know, when I'm having a bad day,
I'm like cupcake.
You know, like go inward
and sit and pop down
and watch Netflix.
Turns out those things
will not nutritiously
feel good for my wellbeing.
Like calling a friend,
doing something active,
trying to learn something new.
You know, those actually are
positive forms of leisure
that will make me feel better.
Problem is your brain doesn't notice it.
It leads you the wrong way.
And so mindfulness can help here, right?
And part of me actually
just literally takes a view of like,
when I'm done an activity,
think about like,
what did that feel like?
Was that nutritionist, was that good?
Like, do I feel yucky now?
And then that causes your brain.
Like the loop that forms habits
can notice like wait, hang on.
That wasn't rewarding, you know,
like really nutritious way.
Maybe I shouldn't do that anymore.
You know, so when you're done, you know,
social media, whatever it was
take a moment to notice,
like, how'd that feel?
So I feel great now, do I feel crummy?
Do I feel kind of more apathetic?
Same with like TV sometimes, right?
Like, you know, there's good TV
and positive TV where you can learn,
but then there's sometimes
it just makes you feel kind
of gross and apathetic.
Notice that.
And then notice the opposite.
Like when I called a friend or
tried to learn something new
or did that big deep breath,
or did that 10 minutes of meditation,
how did that make me feel.
Exercises another big one, right?
You know, do like 10 minutes of just like
hit in your room or grab like a, you know,
quick YouTube like exercise class.
How do you feel afterwards?
Problem is we're so busy.
We don't notice our own rewards.
You know, we just assume like, Oh yeah,
that's scrolling on social
media thing fell awesome.
And we don't take the time
to be like, no, it didn't.
It actually felt kind of crummy.
Like it was an easy thing to do you know,
it was a very low startup costs.
But afterwards I just don't feel great.
But you need to do that like
two seconds of your time
confetti to take time to notice
what's feeling good,
and I can kind of steer
you in the right direction.
- Now, well, this was a super
interesting conversation.
I could talk for many, many more hours.
I hope we get more
chances to discuss this,
but thank you so much, Laurie.
This was hopefully very helpful
and hope it brings a lot of people
on this journey to having
a healthier, happier life.
- Thanks so much for having
me on, this is great.
- Well, thanks everyone for joining.
Hopefully you enjoyed
that as much as I did.
Definitely I'm gonna tweak
a little bit of my time confetti.
Although I have to say,
you know, not to get,
half of my meditation is to
kind of disassociate myself from
my ego and my identity.
But, over the last several years probably
be induced by stress.
I've told many of you all
done a lot more meditation,
it's been a game changer for me.
So I'm gonna underline
everything that Laurie just said.
If you're really daring,
think about Cold Showers,
you can read up about them.
They're a little bit painful going in.
But as Laurie said,
when you're done, you feel great.
And actually you'll save time
because your showers will be shorter.
But don't do it if you're sick,
I don't want to, you know,
people get in trouble
if someone's gets a cold
or something like that.
And yeah, and physical activity, you know,
one thing that I've been trying to do,
one possible when I'm
on zoom or anything like that,
I try to go for a walk, I'll tell people,
okay, I'm turn the camera
off, go for a walk.
I want some fresh air.
I want to walk around
and get my blood flowing.
And these have been the
type of a life hacks
and everything that Laurie just mentioned.
You know, gratitude.
I just got feedback and
at work that, you know,
I'm not thanking people enough.
And I was like, how did I become
that grumpy person who
doesn't thank people.
And over the last week
I've been trying to thank people more,
and Laurie's right.
It makes you happy.
And I'll just remind everyone again,
what Laurie said by donating
doing good for others.
It'll make you happy.
So that's gonna be my new pitch
when I asked for philanthropic
donations for Khan Academy.
So with that, thanks everyone.
I'll see you on Tuesday where we'll do a,
Ask Me Anything.
Have a great weekend.
(beep sound)